nick is in new york city hi nick welcome
to the dave oh to the ramsay show hey
what's up
how you doing dave um i wanted to ask
you
uh i'm 22 turning 23 this year and i
wanted to start saving for my retirement
my company doesn't offer a 401k plan or
anything else
so i was interested in what your
thoughts are
on what kind of rra ira i should get
into a traditional one or a roth one or
something like that or if you have a
better solution i would love to hear it
well good for you man you're welcome
ahead of the way ahead of the curve to
be working on this at your age excellent
so are you out of debt uh yeah i mean
right now the only payment the only
payments i make
are on my phone watch and that's about
60 dollars a month
okay your phone what phone watch my
my cell phone and my smart watch oh i'm
sure together they cost about 60
a month that's just the cellular service
okay yeah
and the uh and and how much money do you
have in savings
um well in my personal savings i have
like a few thousand dollars about three
thousand dollars um but when i was in
the eighth grade
i got hit by a truck so when i was 18 i
got some money from that
and i invested it in stocks about forty
three thousand dollars
in single stocks uh yeah and e-trade and
stuff like that
okay all right um
all right well before we move into
investing i need you to have three to
six months of
household expenses are you on your own
are you living with mom and dad
uh no i still live with my parents okay
all right
your 3 000 probably is your emergency
fund uh
all right to start with nick let's just
back up the first thing is i don't do
single stocks i know a lot about them i
buy i buy investments i've got hundreds
of millions of dollars of investments
and uh but i don't buy single stocks
because i
don't like the risk associated with that
and the game you're playing there's a
lot of risk now if someone is
really loving it and you obviously have
a a knack for it and it's something you
want to fool with
no more than 10 of your net worth
so in your case about 2 000 worth is
about all you ought to have in single
stocks you're taking too much risk in my
opinion
okay so i would move that towards mutual
funds
and then as far as starting few etfs
it's not only
single stocks but it is mainly single
stocks yeah okay
and uh then the next question is when
are you planning to move out and what
money do you need to do that
um i don't really have a plan on moving
out yet i'm still
like i just started working and i
probably would want to move out
between 26 and 28
years old uh possibly yeah
um i'm really not i'm not really sure on
what do you mean with that yeah
what do you make uh about 15
sixteen thousand a year i'm working in a
work study program right now yeah so i'm
not making
a lot of when will you complete the work
study program
uh a few years two years two and a half
okay
when you get your income up to where you
can i don't want you 28 years old in
your mother's basement dude
get out and get going you do not need to
start your roth iras yet
you need to you need to pile up money to
make the transition out of your
household and complete your studies and
complete your career
get your career going then you need to
start and i would start with a roth ira
in good growth stock mutual funds i love
that you're asking the question
but you're a little bit early in your
process not in your age
but in your process you're in the middle
of transit transitional things
that need to happen before you start
investing
yeah i'm just trying to wrap my head
around um
that spirit and also that um
it seems it just seems out of balance
you don't hear that very often that
someone's
thinking so strategically and so far
ahead
and also i'm living to my parents house
i'm about 30
28 you know i mean so it's always the
other way around
i've got people like racing out of their
parents house the moment they can and
buying a way big too big a house or a
truck and saying hey man you gotta have
a future too and so this kind of flipped
around a little bit yeah
yeah yeah get your own place nick get
your own placements
as soon as you're you know you probably
can't do that on 15k uh in new york city
okay but when you get this work study
thing going and you can get your income
coming up in the next 12 to 18 24 months
or whatever then
let's move out get your fully funded
emergency fund at that point of three to
six months of expenses remain and stay
debt free through that whole process and
then you would start investing
when you're stepping into your bet into
your career
and 15 of your income is what i would do
there in good mutual funds
with a good roth ira